the libs are trying to get the
conservative supreme court justices
killed
that's the only explanation i can come
up with as to why a left-wing group just
released the home addresses of amy
barrett john roberts sam alito brett
kavanaugh clarence thomas and neil
gorsuch
the group which calls itself ruth centes
said quote our 6-3 extremist supreme
court routinely issues rulings that hurt
women racial minorities lgbtq plus
and immigrant rights
we must rise up to force accountability
using a diversity of tactics
rise up
force accountability
diversity of tactics
you'll notice peaceful protesting is
only one tactic not hard to figure out
what they mean by diversity of tactics
but this is just one radical group right
just some fringe leftist terrorists that
have nothing to do with actual democrats
in power right
no actually it turns out that the
democrats in power at the highest levels
of power
are refusing to condemn the threats and
intimidation
these activists posted a map with the
home addresses of the supreme court
justices is that the kind of thing this
president wants to help your side make
their point look i think the president's
view is that there's a lot of passion a
lot of fear
a lot of
sadness from many many people across
this country about what they saw in that
leaked document we obviously want
people's privacy to be respected we want
people to protest peacefully if they
want to to protest that is certainly
what the president's view would be
listen sometimes people get passionate
and they send violent mobs to scare or
even attack the families of judges okay
that it's passion right
even by
the libs standards it is hard
for me to believe what i am hearing from
jen saki but then jen saki goes even
further she makes it clear she was not
stuttering
so he doesn't care if they're protesting
outside the supreme court or outside
someone's private residence i don't have
an official u.s government position on
where people protest i want it we want
it of course to be peaceful and
certainly the president would want
people's privacy to be respected but i
think we shouldn't lose the point here
the reason people are protesting is
because women across the country are
worried about their fundamental rights
that have been law for 50 years their
rights to make choices about their own
bodies and their own health care are at
risk that's why people are protesting
they're unhappy they're scared
that's the official white house position
the official white house position on
threats against the lives and families
of the supreme court justices at their
own homes is
f around and find out that's what she's
saying
the crooks who cry crocodile tears over
the horn hat guy dancing around the
capitol rotunda on january 6 the
greatest threat to our north these
people are now shrugging their shoulders
when their own fellow partisans send
angry mobs to intimidate judges families
they want to scare them
they want to scare all of us
they want us all to give up and back
down and hand over the country
the overruling of roe vs wade is the
perfect moment for reflection
it's a time when the libs and even many
conservatives thought that we would be
finished
and now they're starting to realize that
we're only just getting started i'm
michael knowles and this is the 1 000th
episode of the michael knowles show
do we have the technology to bring in
knolls from the room next door
oh my god my this is amazing this is
what will they think of you actually saw
a sausage party did you not i saw it so
that you don't have to do it you wrote
the famously insightful book
reasons to vote for democrats now the
president is being made fun of for
tweeting that it's a great read and this
is the first episode of our show can you
believe they gave me a show i think i'm
the first guy in history to get his own
show for not writing a book
things didn't go as planned inside
umkc's royal hall
this was a warning shot to conservatives
on colleges around the country i came to
hollywood like a million other idiots
looking for a break
instead one day i walked through a door
and found myself transported to a
lunatic fantasy kingdom i have got to
thank the listeners for
engaging with this show subscribing
leaving five star reviews and actually
bringing this show all the way up to the
number one podcast in the country
welcome back to the book club we're
talking with the great larry elder
douglas murray his excellency bishop
robert barron abigail schreier which is
why on crucial matters conservatives
have been left speechless i'm michael
knowles this is the michael knowles show
[Music]
the confines of transmissibility now
going to be loosening up and broadening
them i would like to see a dramatic
diminution of the personal interaction
that we see whatever it takes to do that
that's what i'd like to see
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the show thank you so
much everyone for making it to 1 000
episodes this is wild i i feel
older
i feel
wiser
i feel so grateful to all of you for uh
for sticking around for 1 000 episodes
my favorite comment yesterday from
tanisha rapp who says coming from
someone who used to be a pro-choice
woman watching the coverage on the leak
and seeing all these women just
absolutely refuse to show any empathy
for human life in their body makes me so
sick
of course i used to be one of these
people and it's baffling to me the level
of craziness
such a great point when i was a teenager
i would have called myself pro-choice i
had no problem with abortion i was from
a very liberal place i barely knew any
conservatives i thought the pro-life
issue was all about just controlling
women had nothing to do with babies i
believed all the stuff that the the libs
believe on this and i had my opinion
changed in particular during a
conversation with a bioethicist
but it just happened like that i was
having lunch and this this woman changed
my views
and then i thought more deeply about the
subject and my views deepened rather
quickly over time and then once
once i saw it i couldn't unsee it
it was so i know exactly the kind of
phenomenon you're describing it's why i
try not to be too harsh on the people
like my guest who was on the show
yesterday who are very pro-abortion is i
think there but for the grace of god go
i i used to think that way and then
once you realize that the baby is a baby
you look back and you say how the hell
can anyone not realize the baby's a baby
how can anybody defend this kind of
stuff you know in celebration uh and uh
gratitude for this 1000 episode for all
of you guys the viewers and the
listeners who've made it possible our
show is having a giveaway competition
the prize is a luxurious gift basket
full of michael knowles and daily wire
merchandise you all know about my book
speechless controlling words controlling
mines there it is wow i missed that bill
have you left a five star review yet
have you left an extraordinarily
positive glowing gushing flattering
comment well now is your chance to enter
to win this giveaway uh you must first
be a daily wire member and second you
need to go leave a five star review
paired with whatever beautiful glowing
eloquent review you want and uh then i
will read the reviews choose the winner
so head on over become a member if you
aren't already find speechless on amazon
leave a five star review leave a gushing
personal endorsement and then head over
to the michael knoll show mailbag send
the link to your review with the subject
line mks 1000 so that i and by i mean my
producer don't miss it we'll be
announcing the winner on monday the
1001st episode so make sure to go leave
that review right now thank you again
for being part of the michael knowles
show submit that review in the mailbag
you know we we have been on a big
winning streak i'm not just saying here
at the michael nolsher i'm saying at the
daily wire we sued the federal
government to stop their stupid vaccine
mandate we announced 100 million dollars
to take on woke disney with dw kids well
that makes this the perfect time to get
together with our pals and celebrate
which is why we've got another backstage
live coming up june 29th at the historic
ryman auditorium
it's going to be downtown nashville
tennessee this is your chance to get in
on all these smoke-filled fun and
festivities join me ben matt drew daly
wire guide king jeremy boring
for our biggest live event of the year
tickets go on sale thursday may 12th at
10 a.m central for daily wire all access
members only
12 hours later they'll go on sale for
the general public if you're not an all
access member do not miss out head to
dailywire.com subscribe become an all
access member today that's dailywire
it's going to be the backstage live the
ryman auditorium in nashville june 29th
see you there do we have anything else
to sell guys do we have any more
commercials we can read or can okay i
guess we can get we can get to the show
now for number one that we're going to
be on episode 100 and 2000 by the time
that we get to the actual show today do
you know
what the libs are doing to these
justices is extremely frustrating it's
dispiriting it's sad it's dangerous
but the silver lining is it proves
something that we have been saying on
this show for years
everything the libs accuse us of doing
they do
100 times over
everything
this if this was clear with the russia
hoax
the left spent 100 years shilling for
russia in the united states and then
during the 2016 presidential election
they said that the republicans are
shilling for russia
the libs spent
what 50 hundred years in the united
states undermining and upending norms
and traditions
and liberties and rights and then what
do they say they say you republicans
you're trying to upend our culture and
our rights and everything and then the
lib said in 2020
or january 6 2021 the the conservatives
are posing a violent threat to america
to upend our constitution now what are
they doing they're sending
violent mobs to the homes of supreme
court justices where their children
sleep and the white house shrugs its
shoulders and say well yeah we don't
have a position on where people protest
guess they probably shouldn't have tried
to overrule roe versus wade huh sorry
amy barrett's children yeah i guess
you're gonna have to deal with some
violent mobs f around and find out
that's what they're saying
and joe biden has the goal the audacity
to say that conservatives today
present-day conservatives are the most
extreme political organization in
history
griswold was thought to be a bad
decision by bork and i'm my guess is the
guy's on the supreme court now
what happens if you have a state changes
the law saying that that that children
who are lgbtq can't be in classrooms
with other children
is that is that legit under the way the
decision is written
what are the next things that are going
to be attacked
because this mega crowd is really the
most extreme political organization
that's existed in american history
in recent american history
the most extreme political organization
and he says it with a straight face
because joe biden is a liar and he lies
the same way that he breathes and so
he's probably not even aware of what
he's saying
but the word extreme is a particular
word
i'm not even well i am saying that the
stuff the conservatives are doing
generally is good and the stuff the libs
are doing generally is bad
and i'm sure joe biden also thinks that
the stuff conservatives are doing is bad
and the stuff liberals are doing is good
but he used a different word he said
extreme
and on this point of extreme there can
be no debate
the libs are the extreme ones and they
they brag about that
or they usually do unless they're in an
election year and they realize that's
going to hurt them but there's no
question it's not as though well you
have your opinion and i have my opinion
there actually is an objective answer to
this the libs are the extreme ones
on every single issue it is the libs who
are pushing a view that is extreme that
is to say radical that is to say fringe
that is to say outside of the mainstream
of american thought
on
marriage
there was a definition of marriage for
all of human history until what seven or
eight years ago
and then
most conservatives or at least many
conservatives still hold that opinion of
marriage
the liberals now hold a definition of
marriage that is completely different
that was completely upended by the
supreme court
whatever you think of the definition of
marriage or what the definition of
marriage should be
it is undeniable that the lib's position
is the extreme one that's the one that's
out of sync with all of history and
every civilization and the mainstream
thought
the conservatives is not on the issue of
life that we're talking about now
the conservative view is we really
shouldn't have all this abortion
by the way the mainstream conservative
view isn't even that we need to
overnight get rid of all abortion
everywhere throughout the country i
might prefer that myself but that's not
the mainstream view is send it back to
the states right that's what that's what
you see in justice alito's leaked
opinion
the the left-wing view is abortion on
demand without apology until the moment
of birth and in some cases actually
after birth there was a bill that was
floated in california to permit abortion
after birth i'm not joking in the
perinatal period the former governor of
virginia ralph northam said that after
birth if a mother didn't want her baby
in certain cases they would make the
baby comfortable and decide if they want
to kill it or not
which is the radical again regardless of
your view on life or abortion or
anything like that which is the extreme
view it's it's not difficult to discern
the libs view is the extreme one on
immigration the conservative view is hey
maybe we should reduce all of this
immigration just a little tiny bit at
least illegal immigration that's the
view that's held by the vast majority of
americans the democrat view is
open up the border let in 3 million
people a year 1 million legal 2 million
illegal at least it's probably going to
be more than that
no human being is illegal let's take
down the border wall let's let even more
people in on every single issue it is
the democrats who have the extreme view
you might even like that extreme view i
don't and you probably don't either but
even if you do there is no
question
the democrats right now
are the most extreme political
organization
in the country it's the exact opposite
of what joe biden said it it's almost by
definition we we conservatives generally
are happier with the way things are in
tradition in custom in the rule of law
it is the radicals who want to come in
and subvert that kind of thing
we are not
the aggressors in the culture war
now the culture was ratcheting up people
are getting really really aggressive and
they're they're going to try to use your
data against you okay so you got to
protect it with expressvpn go to
expressvpn.com
knowles if you are using the internet
without expressvpn that is like leaving
your laptop exposed at the coffee shop
table while you're doing your taxes and
you decide to run to the bathroom
doesn't make a whole lot of sense most
of the time you're probably fine but
what if one day you come on out and your
stuff is gone and your information's
gone and your physical stuff is going
that would be crazy every time you
connect to an unencrypted network cafes
hotels and airports any hacker on the
same network can gain access to your
personal data that's passwords that's
financial details that's everything it
does not take much technical knowledge
to hack someone just some cheap hardware
is needed a smart 12 year old could do
it your data are valuable hackers can
make up to one thousand dollars per
person just selling personal info on the
dark web it's super easy to use just
fire up that app click one button to get
protected works on all devices phones
laptops tablets and more i don't go on
my devices without expressvpn i love it
i rely on it on my phone on my computer
secure your online data today by going
to expressvpn.com
exp or
essvpn.com get an extra three months for
free
expressvpn.com
knowles
we are not the aggressors in the culture
war i
have had the distinction
over the past two days
of being condemned not just by one but
by two
american universities
isn't that amazing
one of those universities
is bu
i spoke at bu
a couple of weeks ago a few weeks ago i
gave a talk and uh the the bu
administration really tried to shut this
thing down so i had a sold-out crowd and
then there were people who had shown up
for a uh standby line because there was
some talk that there might be a kind of
a walkout then for whatever reason it
was the police chief or the deputy
police chief there was there was one guy
generally the people we worked with at
this event were very nice and very
accommodating but there was this one
dude i think it was the deputy chief who
just wouldn't let people in wouldn't let
half the audience in wouldn't let our
photographer in we couldn't even get
photographs of the event made the
standby line disperse and and sabotaged
the event
and then at one point a bunch of the
libs in there stood up and yelled and
screamed and they sort of walked out too
and then
they wouldn't let anyone come back in so
it was a bit of sabotage but we at least
got the speech out and now the the bu
student government has just issued a
formal
condemnation of me
said we're disappointed and frustrated
by the boston university
administration's allowance of a speaker
who is openly transphobic
and actively seeks to erode and endanger
the lgbtq community
students expressed their concerns about
safety and the bu administration
continued to be silent and allowed for
the event to occur we fully believe in
freedom of speech and expression however
there you go there's that however
however not for michael however there is
a line between free speech and hate
speech that must be drawn okay
obviously written by not
very well-educated undergraduates
they accuse me of being transphobic
a phobia is an irrational fear of
something i don't have any
fear of
people who have strange sexual confusion
i certainly don't have any irrational
fear of that i'm simply making the
observation that men are not women and
boys are not girls and that it is wrong
for a society to pretend otherwise
because it's a lie and it's a delusion
and it doesn't help anybody not the
people who are confused not the rest of
society that has to pretend and be made
to lie we just shouldn't tolerate that
because it's just not true
regardless of what you think about the
transgender issue
my view is not the extreme one
my view is not the radical one my view
that men can't secretly be women
is the view held by
statistically all human beings
everywhere throughout the entire history
of the world until five seconds ago
the view that men secretly can be women
and are women and we should treat them
as such
that is the extreme view that is the
radical view that is the aggressive view
in the culture now i expect this kind of
thing from boston university
bu is a liberal school in a liberal town
in a liberal state
okay i'm not terribly surprised but it
gets even crazier
because we just found out a couple of
days ago
that another university had invited me
to speak
and the school itself the school
administration preemptively shut it down
and the school
was not some radical secularist school
it's not supposed to be it was a
catholic school
and they took issue with me
for holding the catholic view
of sex and and gender and the and human
nature
this school is the university of st
thomas in minnesota
and
uh the school said
uh this was the university
and the student government so the
university leaders and the student
government said that they would not
permit the student group to bring me to
campus
because i had made comments on
transgender issues that the university
had deemed were in violation of the
quote commitment to dignity and
diversity
and mike what is my comment by the way
they're trying to insinuate that i'm i'm
really insulting or mean or cruel to
people or that i'm calling for violence
against people i haven't done anything
of the sort of course that's why they
never cite any examples here they just
use this vague term that i'm i'm
undermining their dignity and i'm saying
phobic sort of things what is my view
what is the view that is contrary to the
values of the university of saint thomas
my view is that men and women are
different and complementary my view is
the catholic view where did i get my
view the catechism of the catholic
church would be one source if the
university of saint thomas is so shocked
and offended by what i have to say
can you even imagine what will happen
when they read st thomas oh boy fellas
you're really in for something when you
read saint thomas aquinas at the
university of saint thomas because his
views gosh they're even more blunt and
direct and eloquent than mine are aren't
they
it's it's always bad
when conservatives are not allowed to
say conservative things on campus that's
bad and sad and shows you how far the
campuses have fallen
but it is especially absurd when a
catholic is not allowed to say catholic
things at a catholic university
but it's obviously not a catholic
university they're admitting that now
they are saying no we there are
between the two religions that we've got
to pick catholicism
and secular liberalism we're going to
choose secular liberalism a man cannot
serve two masters university of saint
thomas i think they're they're
circulating a petition now to bring me
to speak
i'm happy to speak i'd like to go you
know since the student group invited me
that would be very nice but
much more importantly than that whether
i speak or not i don't i don't really
care ultimately i speak on lots of
college campuses
what is very important here is we have
to expose the administration of the
university of st thomas this is
scandalous the bishops should get
involved because this is a catholic
university the parents who are writing
their tuition checks should get involved
this is a true scandal
if if the if a catholic university isn't
going to teach basic facts about the
difference between men and women then
what are they they're teaching nothing
but extreme radical leftism
that it's dangerous for me to go to a
school and say boys and girls are
different that's apparently dangerous
but when the libs are calling for the
assassination of conservative supreme
court justices that's fine i'm not
exaggerating that by the way the the
liberal group that sent the the mobs to
the justices homes they did not
explicitly call for physical violence
they heavily insinuated it by saying we
want a diversity of tactics
peaceful protesting is fine but we want
a diversity of tactics okay we want you
to go to their homes where their
families live they were heavily
insinuating some blue czech libs came
right out and said it there's this one
guy
simon gwynne
you can tell he's a good person because
he has the ukraine flag in his twitter
name he's calling to assassinate
american supreme court justices but he's
got the ukraine flag so he's a good he
probably wore the mask too so he's a
good guy simon gwynne blue check mark he
says interesting real-life trolley
problem in america right now if you had
the chance to kill clarence thomas and
samuel alito the two oldest right-wing
supreme court justices would you
should you do it while biden can get his
nominees to replace them confirmed
he then goes on and and he says it's
interesting as an abstract question but
becomes a real conundrum if say you're
terminally ill and have little to lose
yourself but know that it could save
many women's lives in the future so he's
not even saying gosh what should we go
out and just kill the judges
i don't know i'm just asking questions
he goes even further than that he says
you know especially if you don't have
that much to lose and these judges
they're killing women somehow that i'm
not exactly explaining how
should you he's saying it should you
do the thing that i'm suggesting is a
good thing and kill
supreme court judges
says the good man with a nice flag in
the blue check mark
this is really
really destabilizing for a country
the economy is already wacky
which is why when you want to make a
strong investment to diversify your
portfolio maybe you've got to check out
masterworks go to masterworks dot io
mk did you know that there is a
lucrative trillion dollar asset class
i'm not talking about crypto i'm not
talking about nfts this particular asset
class has been around for over 275 years
considering that it outpaced the s p 500
throughout the most recent 25 years you
could say it's a time-tested performer
since it outpaced during periods of 3
inflation or higher you might say it has
helped defend the wealth of those who
knew about it and were able to invest in
it while everyday investors are usually
out of the loop on this i'm giving you
the inside scoop and priority access to
this asset class
but it's just too long to reveal in a
60-second ad read so head on over to
masterworks dot io slash mk that's
masterworks dot io slash mk before
deciding to invest carefully review
important disclosures at masterworks dot
io slash cd
this guy simon gwynne this blue check
mark on twitter liberal blue check
suggests that the libs should go and
assassinate sam alito and clarence
thomas in his thought experiment he's
since deleted the tweet
which was allowed to stay up by the way
the twitter didn't take it down
but he's since deleted the tweet he says
okay you know look i get it i'm catching
a lot of heat for this but but that was
his suggestion and i actually think
it's a good thought experiment because
it exposes the extremism of the libs but
it shows you the whole issue of abortion
the the thought experiment that this
blue check poses is should we commit an
action that is intrinsically immoral to
achieve an end that we think is good
even though it's not really good but we
think it's good that's a perfect analog
for abortion
abortion poses this question to people
should we commit an action that we know
is immoral namely killing a baby to
achieve an end that we think is good
namely allowing women to go
work at the widget factory more easily
and not have to deal with children and
go i don't know sleep around in new york
city or something
an end that is not actually good but we
are told it is good because feminists
say it's very liberating for women to be
able to kill their children and not have
any attachments to family and to be
totally autonomous individuals that just
go on lots of tinder dates every night
and have fleeting casual sexual
relationships until they're too old and
the men aren't interested in them
anymore and then they just continue to
work for
whatever man in a position of middle
management is that they have been
convinced as a flourishing life
not to put too fine a point on it but
that is
that is the agenda here that's the
really bleak outlook and yet
the the women are told no having a
family that's that's oppressive that's
terrible that's going to really harm you
and and make you weak but
going to work for some other man in the
city some other man who doesn't care
about you and considers you expendable
and going and sleeping not with a
husband who loves you but with men who
just
treat you for their own pleasure and
then cast you aside that is somehow
empowering
completely backwards
so it's the the good that we are told is
going to be achieved in the end by
killing the supreme court justice or
killing the baby the good is not really
a good it's that's totally dubious but
the question then
even if even if there would were a good
outcome that might come from it
it still doesn't justify it doesn't
justify committing the immoral action of
killing the judges doesn't justify
killing the baby i was asked at yale a
few weeks ago with senator cruz
some guy came up to to play a prank and
get some jokes from his friends and he
said would you
perform a certain sex act on a man if it
would solve world hunger and this was
supposed to be a big gotcha question
because
if you answer yes then hahaha you say
you'll perform a sex act on a man and if
you answer no you're heartless you
wouldn't solve world hunger but it's
actually not a it's only a confusing
question if you
view ethics through the lens of of
consequentialism if you think that the
ends justify the means if you view the
world through this kind of left-wing
utilitarian lens that makes all sorts of
calculations and doesn't think that any
actions are intrinsically morally good
or bad but i'm a conservative baby i'm
not one of these officers economists and
calculators i'm not one of these
rationalist idiots who who thinks the
world operates that way i think that
actions are good and bad in and of
themselves and that's the only thing
that matters
no don't do the weird sex thing with the
dude no don't kill sam alito and
clarence thomas no don't kill the baby
either speaking of death
shocking news
turns out one of the covid vaccines
isn't all that safe
i know stop the presses i know this is
shocking this is the sort of thing i
would have been censored for saying and
was censored for saying a couple of
years ago
but
but certainly within when did the
vaccines come out it came out oh oh
that's right the vaccines came out right
around the time of the presidential
election coincidentally so whenever that
happened we said very early on you know
i think there might be some questions
with these vaccines we were censored for
suggesting any such thing well now
here's cnn
fda put strict limits on johnson and
johnson covid 19 vaccine
and why because people have gotten blood
clots i'm not saying everyone who takes
the vaccine gets a blood clot i'm not
saying even a lot of people who take the
vaccine get get a blood clot but enough
people have gotten blood clots that the
fda is now severely limiting the johnson
johnson vaccine
of the people who got the blood clots
tts
15 of them died
pretty high number
there's another side to this too which
is that the johnson johnson vaccine was
pretty much the nearest to a normal
vaccine that had been used it wasn't
quite as radical as the mrna vaccines
like pfizer and moderna so there is a
question here too
is the government just trying to force
more people to get those particular
vaccines i don't know either way
100 percent safe 100 effective seems to
be
a little bit of a dubious claim which
some of us knew from the very beginning
bill gates though bill gates who for
whatever reason this computer nerd
billionaire has become the face of
vaccines it's fouchy walensky and bill
gates for some reason isn't that weird i
think that's a little weird bill gates
speaking at the 92nd street y he's just
had an epiphany two years in that you
know actually it turns out kovid
acts a little bit differently that we in
the ruling class said it did it wasn't
until early february when i was in a
meeting
that experts at the foundation said
there's no way you know this
there's been too much
uh
travel without diagnosis
for us to contain this
and then at that point we didn't really
understand the fatality rate you know we
didn't understand that it's a fairly low
fatality rate and that it's a disease
mainly of the elderly kind of like
fluids although a bit different than
that so that was pretty scary period
right
where the world didn't go on alert
including the united states
nearly as fast as it needed to
we were really surprised we were really
shocked we just didn't understand that
kovid didn't pose as big of a threat as
we said it was and it mostly affected
the elderly and we
we understood that
that's so funny i'm not a billionaire
i'm not
the face of the public health response
to covid19
i'm and yet i knew that
i knew that
pretty much from the very beginning
that kovid was not as dangerous as they
were all saying it was and that it
affected mostly very elderly people
i you knew that didn't you knew that i
think you probably knew that you
suspected that
most people i knew who were not liberal
most conservatives i knew not all of
them but most conservatives i knew
understood that
two years ago
we got the data that came out of italy
almost right away we had the data in the
united states we we knew we all and you
know i think bill gates knew it too
and i think fouchy knew it and i think
walensky probably knew it i don't think
it's just incompetence i think
that either they're the dumbest people
on the face of the earth which is pretty
surprising
or
they knew it and they just decided to
drag this whole thing out to take more
power and to take more money
the two years of the
covid lockdowns the public health
response represented the largest shift
in wealth from the lower classes to the
upper classes in the history of the
world the two years of the coveted
response represented a major shift in
power from the people and from the
states to the federal government to
technocrats and to international
organizations
oops and oops we got it wrong guys wow
who could have seen it who could have
seen it buster i don't know all of us
could have and now you have the audacity
to urinate on our leg and tell us that
it is raining speaking of water very
important to go check out one more wave
go to
1mwave.com
daily wire i am so excited to talk about
this company that is really making a
difference for our nation's veterans
that is one more wave one more wave uses
surf therapy to help veterans stay
active engaged and connected the founder
of one more wave alex west is a retired
navy seal who noticed that for many
veterans especially those with adaptive
needs standard off-the-shelf surfboards
and equipment were off the table so what
did he do he created a team of surfboard
artists and surf instructors to work
with grant recipients to design the
custom equipment for their experience
level and physical needs from there one
more wave connects veterans to their
global network of surfing volunteers who
empower them to heal through surf
therapy from coast to coast fresh salt
air sunshine and the exhilaration of
flying down the face of a wave keep more
and more veterans coming back for more
since 2015 one more wave has empowered
over 500 veterans to find healing and
community through surf therapy by
providing custom surfing equipment and
community they need your ongoing support
help fund 10 new surf therapy grants by
going to
1mwave.com daily wire it's a number one
letter m wave.com slash daily wire sign
up to become a monthly sustaining donor
the average veteran grant costs 2 500
bucks every tax deductible donation
counts help us to continue to support
those brave men and women who have given
so much for this nation 1mwave.com daily
wire become a sustaining member one more
wave is 501c3 your donation is tax
deductible1mwave.com for more
information
we're so excited guys we're about to
come up to my favorite time of the week
the mailbag when i get to hear from all
of you but we've hit episode 1000
the the libs think that we're reaching
the end they think oh roe versus wade is
we're just we're reaching the end of the
conservative movement no
we're only getting started both in
politics and on this show we've got a
lot more fun content coming up stuff
that i i can't tell you all about it uh
just yet but some changes to the show
some some new content coming out for the
next 1000 episodes one piece of that i
had the opportunity to sit down recently
with the smartest man in the world
before we get into metaphysics the
existence of god free will politics
culture i know people are going to be
asking why is the smartest man in the
world living on a farm
in the middle of missouri i would read
these books i was living in a covered
wagon they call it a sheep wagon reading
bertrand russell and albert reading
bertrand wrestle on albert einstein and
it occurred to me these two things
really need to be put together the ctmu
is the cognitive theoretic model of the
union this is your theory of everything
when you take away the points those zero
dimensional points now all of that
disappears they look at everything in a
cartesian theater do we have free will
and a real manifold is just a space
consisting of points in which each point
has a locally euclidean neighborhood can
you put that into more basic terms what
was it you you need to understand about
this traditionally it's understood that
satan and lucifer are the same is the
devil real
oh yes this is
pretty much inescapable
[Music]
we got a whole lot more coming up folks
we've got much more
live interaction we've got much more
in-depth conversation with people you
probably haven't heard from we've got
in-depth docuseries we got all of it
okay
and starting today in honor of my 1000th
episode my entire collection in the
daily wire shop will be 25 off for the
weekend with code knowles one thousand
get your hands on the coveted
nostradamus line okay that's my favorite
one that's out there uh we've got the
faucet
faucet
merchandise we've got books we got books
with words we got books without words we
even have a one thousandth episode
commemorative pin featuring your
favorites for the daily wire host aye
nolstradamus uh will uh be featured in
there so make sure you head on over
dailywire.com
shop today we'll be right back with the
mailbag
welcome back to my favorite time of the
week when i get to hear from you in the
mailbag which is sponsored by puretalk
get unlimited talk text and six gigs of
data for just 30 bucks a month go to
puretalk.com shop for the plan that's
right for you today first question up
from robert dear mr knowles
so i'm pretty sure i know what your
response will be but i'll ask my
question anyways
i'm dating a wonderful catholic girl and
i'm catholic myself i'm 33 and she's 21.
all right i'm not you know i was going
to say hey nice buddy but you know
listen uh my grandparents were 12 years
apart i mean that didn't used to be so
unusual as it is now uh we haven't been
dating very long six months but i do
care a lot about her we are intimate
with each other and unfortunately the
contraceptive broke and we are waiting
to see if we're pregnant or not i know
abortion's wrong so i don't want to put
that on her or on my soul
but i know we aren't ready and it
terrifies me a bit do you have any
advice or guidance to help me through
this also i do plan on speaking with a
priest in the near future but i would
love to have some advice
or guidance from you sincerely a
terrified possibly new father okay first
thing
take a breath
pause this is like what you would say to
a medical doctor first do no harm i know
this could be very scary you you could
be freaking out i'm certain you are
freaking out don't do anything rash or
crazy or anything that you're going to
regret which you understand first thing
do not abort the baby
if there is a baby you don't even know
if
if your girlfriend is pregnant yet it's
actually harder to get pregnant than a
lot of people think that it is i know in
health class now they they teach you
that if you even look at a girl the
wrong way she's going to get pregnant
that's actually not really how it works
generally
but
if she is pregnant do not abort the baby
if you want
to raise the baby
if you like this girl
if you think that you get along well
together and you could have a long-term
future together
then just get married get married
quickly it's okay
john lennon i think once made the wry
comment that most babies in history have
been born out of a whiskey bottle
which is a little little cynical but
but there's probably some truth to that
and there have been shotgun marriages
that have turned out really great okay
so
if you like the girl and the girl likes
you and you think this could be a
serious thing and you were thinking that
while you were dating her huh we might
really end up together and now you're in
this situation where you might have a
baby well look that might be an
opportunity to get married
and you don't need to bury your head in
shame about it and you don't you can
just get married you could have a good
life
if you say no we're we don't want we
really don't want to get married or we
really don't want to raise this baby
then give the baby up for adoption
you can do that again you don't need to
bury your head and shame about that
adoption can be a very beautiful thing
there's an estimated 36 couples in the
united states for every single baby put
up for adoption so you will find a
loving home for this baby
if you want to do that okay now putting
those questions aside for a second
what should you do into the future uh
you should stop doing that thing that
that only married people are supposed to
do because
well i guess you've just proved it right
because these sorts of things can happen
and sex is for a purpose and yep i know
it's a fallen world and we live in a
time of casual sex and so i'm not really
passing judgments here on you but i am
passing a judgment on the action and you
recognize that now too so you and your
girlfriend should cut that out and then
you know get married and uh you know
then
go to town have a good time uh you say
you want to go talk to a priest about
this yes you should go priest confess
the sin perhaps get some advice probably
the priest is
more thoughtful about this than i am but
there it is that's i'm giving you a very
technical answer because i know that you
are in
a
really technical moment where you're
going to have to make certain decisions
and you're going to have a lot of
cultural pressure to push you in the
wrong direction
do not do that first
first things first
do no harm
and then potentially look at this as a
good opportunity from michael
hey michael long time listener love the
show question regarding another recent
mailbag question you said we should just
move on and understand that the libs
might have been going through something
and not let their insane kovidge stick
get to us my question is what are your
thoughts on the people that still buy
into the insanity
even as we are well into year three
thanks for the amazing show great
question i was asked this week or two
ago they said look i'm just so angry at
some of my friends and relatives who
wouldn't see me during covid who were so
crazy about it it's hard for me to move
on and my answer was you just move on
it's okay look they were neurotic they
they lost their minds
uh you did not but
look kiss it up to god suffer silently
move on if you don't want to lose your
friends and family it's okay be have a
little grace
what if your friends and family are
still sticking with the kovid mania well
you should laugh about it not in a
mocking way but it's a sort of hey guys
you know come on it's over all right
it's you're gonna be okay no but what if
i show up to the party and i have and
then someone sneezes it's gonna be
there's germs okay they're gonna be
germs forever and you know what you're
gonna get sick again at some point and
that's okay
that's the way the world goes no well i
don't wanna go well you don't need to
come to my party you don't need to come
get dinner tonight you don't need to
come over to the house but
you're invited we're all going to move
on with our lives and if you want to
live again too you're more than welcome
but if you don't want to i can't make
you
that would be my attitude
warm
loving but don't you can't play into
this you really shouldn't have played
into this from the beginning but
certainly not now from ricky hey michael
with the current uh cultural climate
being so supportive of child sacrifice
and now even major companies supporting
these same disc disordered ideals such
as amazon i'm increasingly concerned
about how i as a consumer support these
fundamentally immoral ideals through my
purchases obviously i can stop shopping
through amazon and cancel prime
membership etc which our family firmly
intends to do
but it's increasingly hard to know where
other companies stand on this issue to
or whether they are supporting
organizations like planned parenthood
how do you go about vetting where you
shop and learning about their political
beliefs so as not to inadvertently
support abortion
well you you are supporting abortion by
living in the united states you're
supporting abortion your tax dollars are
going to planned parenthood and planned
parenthood is butchering babies and it's
an abortion mill and we have laws on the
books that pretend that your dollars are
not going to abortions themselves but
money is fungible and so if you're
funding abortionist organizations you
are funding abortion okay and you're
doing it not just through your tax
dollars but you're doing it through
i don't know your pension plans you're
doing it through your
employment maybe your employer is is
donating some money or matching some
funds or giving to some corporation
you're doing it when you go and shop at
a store and if that if that store is
going to
offer some kind of matching funds or
some kind of insurance program they're
going to buy into an insurance program
that is covering abortions and so you
are going to have
some
indirect contact with evil
and some indirect involvement with evil
it's it's almost unavoidable
i guess not totally unavoidable but it's
it's practically almost unavoidable uh
and and so there is a distinction to be
made with indirect
uh
indirect association with evil and and
direct evil actions uh where does amazon
fall on that list
i don't know
i don't know exactly they said in a in a
company meeting that they would pay for
their employees to go travel out of
state to get an abortion that seems to
be like a heightening of their of their
contact with abortion and their
involvement with it but lots of
companies do lots of similar things i
remember some years ago starbucks said
that as part of one of their charity
drives they would match to a certain
amount of money
a donation that the employees made to
their favorite charity and one of the
charities was planned parenthood
does that mean we can't get coffee there
anymore well i don't know i think if you
apply that kind of a threshold then you
can't really participate at all in the
economy whatsoever
so
you know
this is going to be an unsatisfying
answer to you but i think it's a simple
answer
it does help to buy local it does help
to buy from people that you know that is
increasingly difficult in an economy so
i
in an economy that's now mostly digital
and national and even international so
my answer is do the best you can but you
can't be overly scrupulous about this
because
because there is so much evil
particularly on this issue of abortion
just enmeshed into the fabric of society
and that's why we need political action
to disentangle that that's why your your
commercial action is not going to be
enough you need more political action
from anonymous dear mr knowles what can
a nobody like me
who will never have more than a handful
of followers on social media
do to help the conservative cause do i
just like stuff do i just post and
retweet keep in mind i don't anticipate
ever having any followers really what
practical thing can a guy like me do to
help even if i'm largely irrelevant i
understand that large movements can be
made up of people of small stature yes i
mean every political movement that's
ever mattered has
been propelled by people whose names you
don't know
right so that that's obviously the case
in terms of social media even if you
don't have a lot of followers it
actually does help to post things
because the more shares that something
gets on social media platforms generally
the more momentum it can get it can pop
up higher in the algorithm
so that actually can be helpful i'm not
saying don't like stuff don't post stuff
don't share stuff
that is helpful
um
but there's a world beyond social media
too
what you could do that would probably be
even more effective much more effective
than posting or liking something in the
virtual world is getting out into the
physical world and going to a meeting of
your local republican committee or your
local conservative group or going out
and helping a campaign
or going out if if you're more
commercially oriented and starting a
business to offer an alternative to some
of the woke companies out there
that real action in the real world could
have a whole lot more effect frankly
even if you just talk to people in your
town
just talk to people at a coffee shop at
a restaurant your friends your family
your extended family
and you speak to them in in real life
that could have a much more significant
effect than just posting something on
social media when my mind has really
been changed on issues
and it's been changed on really
important issues it was changed on
abortion it was changed on the existence
of god it was changed on all sorts of
things
generally speaking it was changed
because of face-to-face interactions
and then i would read some stuff and i
would see some videos and i would watch
interviews and i would read books and
but the face-to-face stuff the personal
connection can can make a huge
difference from daniel hey michael you
say he who pays the piper calls the tune
i say he who pays has the saves
well well your quote sounds much more
eloquent i've been giving it some
thought on how it applies to men losing
the ability to be the man of his own
house it is much more common today that
both parents are working so if both are
paying who's doing the saying
do you believe the push for women to go
to work has undermined a husband's
ability to be the head of the household
certainly it has
i don't think it necessarily does
because
even this whole idea of women working
really is a bit of revisionist history
women have always worked women have
always worked as hard or harder
than men have
but the work was not always the
identical work when i think about the
stuff that sweet little elisa does even
forget about any of her professional
activities or professional outside of
the home just the stuff she does in the
home in the family with regard to our
community with regard to helping me
she's the only person i trust to help
write my show
she was the only person i really trust
to give me jokes and zingers when i
think of all she works more than i do
at least as much as i do she works at
least as much as i do but it's different
work
and the work that i do she would hate
doing
and and wouldn't want to do it at all
and the work that she does i would just
not be good at whatsoever
and probably not enjoy a whole lot of it
so
what second wave feminism in particular
did was say women if you want to have
any value at all you need to go work at
the widget factory that's what that
guest i had on yesterday bronte remzyk
said she said you're devaluing women by
suggesting that they be mothers and
homemakers devalu i think i'm valuing
them actually i think i'm saying that
women doing
women have value even when they're not
doing things traditionally associated
with men
so i'm a big defender of
sex roles you know that's spousal roles
husbands doing husband things and wives
doing live things
and that that doesn't need to be
oppressive and patriarchal or what you
know whatever terms they throw at you
it means that
there's a role for men and there's a
role for women and people are happier
when they when they do those things and
you can support one another and you can
both work and you can have respect and
i'm not even saying the women can't work
outside of the home but if if there is a
recognition that uh
men and women are different and
complement one another you're going to
get along much better john wayne made
the point that america is actually a
matriarchy always has been that women
wield so much more power than men do
but maybe men have more nominal power
and maybe men make the final decision on
something in the home or with regard to
the family but women the hand that rocks
the cradle rules the world women
generally run most of the home economy
and women generally run most of the
lives of the men and so
so i i just think that is
people were happier society functioned a
lot better when we recognized that plain
fact of the world on that very
politically incorrect point
i'm michael knowles this is the 1000th
episode thank you so much for coming
with us this far look forward to seeing
you for the 2000th episode this is the
michael knowles show
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022.
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin